[Music]
foreign
briefing for Friday March 24th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
on Thursday tick tock's CEO Sho Chu
testified before the house Energy and
Commerce Committee
and from the start the exchanges between
the tick tock boss and U.S lawmakers
were firing
here's the committee's chair Washington
representative Kathy McMorris Rogers
questioning chew as I previously
referenced Tick Tock spite on American
journalists can you say with 100
certainty that neither bite dance nor
Tick-Tock employees can Target other
Americans with similar surveillance
techniques chair Rogers I first of all
disagree with the characterization that
is spying it was an internal
investigation yes or no can you do
surveillance of other Americans we will
protect the U.S user data and fire it
all from all unwanted foreign access
it's a commitment that we've given to
the committee so so I guess my question
is are can I want you to I wanted to
hear you say with 100 certainty that
neither bitness nor Tick Tock employees
can Target other Americans with similar
surveillance techniques as you did with
the journalists
again I I don't disagree with the
characterization characterization is
surveillance and we have given our
commitments chair Rogers the four
commitments I think it's our commitment
that we will not be influenced by any
government with me to discuss what else
happened at the hearing and what it
means for tick tock's future is wsj Tech
policy reporter John McKinnon hi John
thanks for joining me oh you're welcome
so John we just heard that fiery
interaction between Chu and chair Rogers
was that the tone throughout the hearing
it certainly was I was really surprised
to hear so many unfriendly questions
from so many lawmakers in a row must
have been quite an experience for Mr Chu
the US government is threatening to ban
Tick Tock in the country if it's Chinese
owners don't sell their stake did it
seem like Chu's testimony did anything
to prevent that from being the outcome I
don't think that his testimony has done
too much to advance tick tocks cause or
win many more friends in Congress than
it currently has which is not very many
that said I think that he did a pretty
good job of hanging in there and taking
the hits and there was no knockout I
would say he didn't really get angry or
lash out at any of the questions that he
was getting he maintained his
equilibrium so in a sense he might have
bought some time for tick tock because
one thing that Congress is not very good
at is doing things quickly and I think
maybe Tick Tock hopes that if Congress
drags this out for a lot longer then
Tick Tock has a hope of finally winning
people over to its point of view were
there any specific interactions during
the hearing that stood out to you I was
struck by some questions that came from
representative camach she's a republican
from Florida she showed a Tick-Tock
video that depicted a handgun firing and
it had a caption that mentioned the
hearing that went on
and also mentioned the chair of the
committee that was holding the hearing
Kathy McMorris Rogers from Washington
this video has been up for 41 days it is
a direct threat to the chairwoman of
this committee the people in this room
and yet it Still Remains on the platform
and you expect us to believe that you
are capable of maintaining the data
security privacy and security of 150
million Americans where you can't even
protect the people in this room
you know we know that Tick Tock has this
plan called project Texas to house U.S
users data with the cloud company Oracle
that's based in Austin did to make any
other pledges about users data or
protecting U.S users he had a pretty
carefully crafted formula of a series of
security promises most of which are
embodied in Project Texas and he kept
coming back to that over and over Tick
Tock has this very extensive set of
promises on security and privacy that
they say is really an industry leader
and that other tech companies don't do
anything like what they're promising to
do and they're hoping that that's going
to be a sufficient alternative to either
Banning Tick Tock or trying to force a
sale of tick tock to essentially a
non-chinese company has China reacted at
all to the idea that the U.S might Force
the sale of tick tock yes the Chinese
government put out a statement that
basically said that any sale of tick
tock would involve the export of Chinese
technology and therefore would have to
be approved by the Chinese government
and this occurred right before the
hearing started
and created quite a stir I would say
with the members of Congress who in a
way I think it put Tick Tock in a
tougher position because it suggested
that China's really on the side of bite
dance and Tick Tock bite dance being
tick tock's parent interesting I want I
want to turn to another issue that's
been raised concerning Tick Tock that's
the issue of young users on the platform
Representative Bob Latta he's a
republican from Ohio he told this story
about a 10 year old girl who
participated in a breath-holding
challenge that was popular on Tick Tock
I just want to play this clip from
representative Latta unfortunately this
is one of the many devastating examples
of children losing their lives because
of content promoted by tick tock
section 230 was never intended to Shield
companies like yours from amplifying
dangerous and life-threatening content
to Children he mentioned section 230
there that is what prevents platforms
from being liable for information that
their users put up but how much did this
issue of child safety come up at the
hearing and how did Chu respond oh it
was a consistent theme in this hearing
and there were all kinds of examples the
one that Mr Lotter was talking about is
known as the Blackout Challenge there's
also the milk crate challenge the NyQuil
chicken challenge the Benadryl challenge
there's a challenge that promotes car
theft so members brought a lot of these
up over and over I would say and they
also brought in comparisons to the
sister app of tick tock in China which
is called do yin and noted that this
kind of thing just doesn't happen on
that app and so it was a really really
tough line of questioning for Mr Chu
Tick Tock has announced a lot of sort of
special protective policies for children
on the app and again a lot of these are
industry leading standards according to
tick tock and they
um you know are very careful to give a
different type of content to younger
children who identify as as younger the
problem with all of these protections is
they depend on knowing how old the kid
is who's using the app and quite often
they don't know quite often the kids can
say they're older than they really are
and these protections just don't work
all that well but at least they were
prepared for it but I don't think a lot
of members were won over okay so what
happens next what comes next is a little
bit less clear Congress you know is
never very quick out of the blocks and
so we've gotten a hearing where a lot of
members expressed a lot of concern even
anger at some points with Tick Tock but
it's still not clear exactly what
Congress can do and perhaps more
important when it can do it alright
that's wsj Tech policy reporter John
McKinnon and that's it for Tech news
briefing this week but another quick
reminder before we close the show that
we still want to hear your questions
about generative artificial intelligence
do you want to know more about programs
like chat GPT Microsoft's new Bing
search or Google's new Bard email us a
voice recording to tnb wsj.com or leave
your AI question as a voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
tnb's producer is Julie Chang we had
production assistants from Zoe Culkin
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
Tinsley I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening and
have a great weekend
[Music]